yo it's the calm before the storm right
here wait how's it gonna start this off
oh yeah that's an awfully hot pot of
coffee should I drop it on Donald Trump
or not probably not until I develop a
solid block got a plan now I got a
hatchet like I did Apache with the
tomahawk of a walking inside of Moscow
Ramadan say a prayer that everytime
Melania opens them I'm gonna stop I just
I feel like that I feel like it's not
landing where it's gold you're doing
great kid I don't like that the whole
Apache thinks and kind of sensitive you
know like with them don't worry about a
kid just read this get back out there
yeah cuz racism's the only thing he's
fantastic for that's how we get this
rocks off and he's orange strong why
it's gold oh man I feel like it's played
out thing like orange I said I wanted
some fresh material you're doing great
kid no one can touch it now get out
there and rap but read the materials
no yeah this is for Colin Bowl over fist
and keep this ball like Donald the [ __ ]
yeah you're crazy you just called the
president a United States a fickle [ __ ]
black people love that it's B et now get
back out there yeah yo he's gonna get
rid of all immigrants Donald's gonna
build that taller than this well if he
does build - I hope it's made out of
bricks cuz like his politics I'm coming
non-stop and I'm on watch at the wall
till it sticks looks force alright yo
for anyone who's a fan of mine in here
is I'm drawing a line in the sand you're
either for or against well you don't
want to split the market there kid
oh I gotta do this I gotta be real just
a just be real without pissing off half
the country just there just call him a
big old [ __ ] right just a that worked
right yeah when you call them an orange
[ __ ] right [ __ ]